you had a sentence in your book that I
thought was maybe the strong ascendants
I'd ever seen from a business leader
that uh I was not aware of until I read
your book in full which was you said
that you think that the odds of America
slipping into a civil war type scenario
over the next 10 years is around 30
percent and you characterize that as
like not that high a risk I feel like
that should be A1 headline news
everywhere and by the way I'm with you
like I I agree with you here's what I
think is happening and and probably will
happen the populism of the left and the
right uh are individuals who will are
Fighters for those constituencies and uh
there are very different values very
different approaches what that means is
that there's little compromise and
there's much greater extremism very much
like happened in Europe four major
democracies in the 1930 to 45 period had
this type of internal conflict that
ended up their parliaments their uh
legislatures choosing to have
autocracies that they went to
autocracies on Germany Italy Japan and
Spain and if you study history you see
it was the same in the fresh Revolution
the Russian Revolution the Cuban
Revolution the Chinese Revolution which
are all sort of Civil Wars you lose the
middle and because you have to say
Andrew you got to get on one side or
another and fight when the causes that
people are behind are more important to
them than the system the system is in
Jeopardy and so you see just even people
moving from place to place in terms of
where they think it's more uh
sympathetic to their way of being and
what they're like you know New York
Chicago San Francisco California moves
to Texas and so on and you're seeing um
then
um not a not as much respect for the
Constitution and the legal system
because you have a win at all cost so
for example if you have the dispute
between
um let's say Disney and the Florida
governor in the past there would have
been almost mutual respect for different
points of view but what you now get back
is you get back to a power conflict well
you know what would the odds put I'll
ask you what you think the odds are that
for example example in the next
presidential election that neither side
accepts losing you know I'd say almost
too close to call
um and what is the possibility that
states do not follow the directions of
the Supreme Court decisions because the
Supreme Court decisions can be viewed by
one side as a political decision made by
the other Supreme Court and how do we
get around that or whatever just like
Sanctuary cities in other words I will
not follow that rule and that and so now
you start to have a breakdown of the
system and you have power politics
determining things so I think that that
kind of uh Civil War is relatively
likely I I don't disagree with you at
all Ray anyone who listens to me knows
that I've been trying to sound an alarm
on this so one of the things you say in
your book is that you think one way out
of this is a strong Peacemaker and we
pray for them but you say that that's
not something that uh generally happens
uh that generally the other thing
happens
um what what I'm trying to do have you
seen any of uh Catherine Galler
Michael's or Michael Porter's work on
political incentives because well one of
the things that's driving our
polarization is that we have these party
primaries that disproportionately
empower the most extreme 10 of partisan
voters so one thing we're trying to do
is change the mechanics of our election
so that it's not just the most extreme
uh hyper partisans choosing our leaders
and then re-electing them right now you
have 20 of Americans happy with Congress
which is very very low uh but the
re-election rate for individual members
is 94 which is astronomically high but
your book talks about the increase in
polarization as a precursor to some of
these very negative things happening and
there are other societies that have
democracies that have more than two
parties that's actually the norm in most
of the world and so what we're trying to
do it Forward is change the mechanics so
that you can have more points of view
emerge and then start a positive
unifying third-party force that
represents the reasonable middle that
can draw energy and resources and also
put pressure on both of the parties to
compromise I I don't know if this is
something that you've dug into and
explored either in terms of the
mechanics of why it seems like we're
getting uh more extreme and polarized
leadership or if there have been other
countries that have reformed their way
out so I I think we're completely in
agreement much and just going back to
the mechanics I I think it has to do
fear I hope
that we can have understand what the
context what what it means to have the
type of Civil War the what is the
probability and what does that mean
um like I have a principle if you worry
you don't have to worry and if you don't
worry you need to worry that's a pretty
good rule of life if you worry
you'll take care of the thing you're
worrying about and you can worry less
and and if you don't then probably it'll
kill you the extremism
which
um has problems in terms of destroying a
system is a terrible path anybody who's
gone through this and I I mean it
domestically as well as internationally
but the number one thing is that the
population has got to want that and we
have and in our two-party system we have
a problem because
um let's say there's about 30 percent of
the population I I would Define as being
uh rather uh extreme right and maybe
something like 15 of the population
being extreme left but as a percentage
of their uh uh own parties they're
relatively high and they're Gathering
more as their as the fight approaches
and so they become then dominant and you
have that particular result but the
power of the middle if you can and and
the power of of of those so compromise
if you can bring that about is enormous
because still the majority of people are
not in those two we're we're talking
about 45 percent of the population maybe
is is fairly extreme and an opposite
ends
um but the majority still aren't there
and if the majority had they have to be
smart enough to know how to increase the
size of the pie and divide the pie well
to produce equal opportunity and and
equal and some element of sharing it to
get the balance right you wrote a number
of pieces in 2018 and 2019 about how we
need to try and reform the economy or
reform capitalism capitalism so that it
works for more people and one of the
stats that you cited was a stat that I
cited to on the trail which was that the
odds of American children doing better
than their parents uh are down to let's
say 50 50 and dropping which is one of
the thing things that's driving people
to anger frustration I mean it's very
fundamental you're a parent I'm a parent
if you felt like your kids are going to
do worse than you then you start looking
around being like okay what the heck is
is going wrong yes I wrote a study which
was why and how capitalism needs to be
reformed which was a very controversial
study but but it's an obvious fact that
if it's not benefiting the majority of
the people okay then just by its metrics
of success it's not a it's not going to
be successful and there are and reformed
doesn't mean gone away with it means
changing certain things that means it
works better keeping capitalism and so
on capitalists tend to be people who um
have new ideas and if you give them
capital and they can invent really good
things and improve it you know it's a
wonderful system it's been proven by
everybody it's been adopted by the
Chinese thing Xiaoping to make a better
uh system but it has to work in a way
where it produces the outcomes that you
want the middle the problem is
capitalists are better able of
increasing the pie but they don't know
how to divide the pie well they don't
have to share it well and socialists um
don't know how to make it as good a pie
but they divide it well so I think you
need the bipartisan like if I was
President of the United States which by
the way I will never be I'm not right
but I would want to have a bipartisan
cabinet
okay I'd put a bipartisan cabinet and I
would have the equivalent to a Manhattan
Project to think about what reforms need
to be made to achieve that uh in other
words of the left of the right smart
capable mechanical at least Savvy
individuals who know about engineering
and there will have to be structural
changes for example let's say education
on the Constitution uh makes
um education a state issue which then is
in Most states become the local tax
District issue I know this well because
my wife
um and I to some except that her really
works and the worst school districts in
Connecticut I'll give you a stock
shocking statistic in Connecticut which
is one of the richest states in the
country 22 percent of the high school
students are either disengaged or
disconnected disengaged means that their
absentee rate is greater than 25 percent
their failing class oh my gosh and
disconnected means that they don't know
where they are because they dropped out
of school 22 percent of the high school
students are failing high school now
there's a cycle there they're in a poor
District they're not they don't have
parents to adequately take care of them
and so on the state of Connecticut spend
600 billion dollars a million dollars a
year on
um incarcerations
because there's that so the notion you
know like there's no better investment
than quality education
but these types of changes some have to
be reformed maybe it requires some
Constitutional Amendments but it
certainly means working together because
the country or the world as a whole has
more resources than it ever had it has
more intelligence than it ever had but
it has a choice is it going to go to war
or is it and which will make things
worse than ever or is it going to try to
find a way and together to make that
better whole that's the choice I think
we face
foreign
[Music]